[Music]
there we go it's starting to get a
little tired
come on come on
come
on
says I don't care you want us to check
to see if there's a record close to be
able to help you yeah hello
foreign
yes ma'am I'm on top of 11 foot Gator
let me call you right back
let me see if there's a friendly record
that can help us lift this alligator
into the competitive truck
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's get him over here on the
road here
we would go ahead and roll
yeah
zero
[Music]
he's a bit fatty
[Music]
[Applause]
that'll work
[Music]
there we go
back up
all right
coming up more
down
all right all right
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes and he's gonna relocate him to a
gator team tour
no
one want to claim it
no no no no no two rolls and you get
hurt no no he can't afford that okay
he's going to a sanctuary yeah
he's gonna be relocated to the sanctuary
he measured uh two foot six with a
little bit of growth
it's a little bit of curl yeah
I thought it was gonna be a bit bigger
than me
we live right there
so I'm walking about five bucks
thank y'all so much
Danny Danny
watch the cars
[Applause]
go ahead
okay
come on
thank you
hey Tim where did you say you're going
to relocate them too so get a country in
Beaumont
really I was in between winning and
Beaumont okay
yep yep
Jesse Yeah
wow
let me turn my truck around real quick
hey guys hey guys we got to move the
truck around so everybody step back
please
thank you great job
thank you
can you stop him yeah let them let these
two through
okay thank you
[Applause]
sir sir
he's gonna turn around
you'll get another opportunity all right
thank you
yeah
he measured it ten foot seven
sure sure
[Applause]
[Applause]
he's not he's going to sanctuary
[Laughter]